but i would always abandon myself
to make someone else happy to create a
sense of peace
in that moment an environment of peace
and what i've learned is you can't buy
peace you can't pay someone off for them
to then be happy
because then they'll keep doing it uh
and they'll never be happy
it doesn't solve a problem yeah so i
would just be like screw this this
person doesn't get me
no matter what i give to them they're
never happy and
it's their fault and they're ungrateful
and
and i'm out
[Music]
welcome to episode 86 of the michaela
peterson podcast
on this episode i spoke with lewis howes
for some reason i was kind of skeptical
about lewis howes
probably because of the podcast school
of greatness and i was like
who is this guy school of greatness
however
i love him he's such a good guy he also
spent a solid
hour after the podcast giving me podcast
tips
he's a wonderful human if you don't know
him lewis howes is a podcast host
author and entrepreneur he started his
highly successful podcast show school of
greatness in 2013.
this episode went completely differently
than i expected
and we discussed therapy self-care
self-understanding emotional triggers
adapting to life creating positive
emotional outlets
studying emotion in kids and more we
also talk about podcast
life a bit if you enjoy this episode
please remember to hit subscribe
thanks to luis for coming on my podcast
and giving me tips much
appreciated this episode is brought to
you by hover
a domain name vendor that is absolutely
wonderful
for sponsoring me so if you need a
website show them some love
so they keep sponsoring me something
that makes hover special
is it has a ton of options for different
endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose from when building your brand
online
you can end your website in a dot blog
or dot diet or whatever instead of a dot
com
if you so choose i use hover for that
reason
adding a dot something to your website
can be a better idea than a full on new
dot com
i personally own at least 10 domains
i've bought every iteration of michaela
peterson that you guys can spell wrong
it's not your fault my dad named me
after macaula garbachev and nobody knows
how to spell that
i cannot recommend buying domains from
hover enough you'll find
excellent technical support available to
answer any questions you may have
their support team doesn't upsell you
they have free whois
privacy protection a clean user
experience and
monthly sales on popular top level
domains
check them out at hover.com mp
that's h o v e r dot com slash mp
and you get 10 off discount with that
code
having a website is so important for
anyone with a business to be taken
seriously
especially if you're less likely to be
taken seriously because you do intros
with a bathing suit
hover.com mp linked below enjoy this
episode
i definitely did
[Music]
lewis howes welcome to my podcast thank
you for having me appreciate it
this is kind of exciting i'm excited i'm
glad you're here
i'm very grateful very grateful
well thank you very much so my how are
you doing today
i feel i feel grateful um
i think i was talking to your dad last
time i talked to him about how
powerful therapy can be for people
if they're willing to like dive into
their darkness if they're willing to
dive into
and look at their demons and figure out
why is it still
making them like a prisoner or why they
still in reaction mode or aggressive or
not forgiving or whatever and so i've
been doing some
some powerful uh coaching therapy in the
last few months to help me overcome like
certain triggers and it's been
extremely challenging but also i feel
like i'm actually able to
see it when it's happening and respond
from a different place of gratitude and
peace so i'm feeling really good in this
moment
okay that's interesting though the way
the way that you describe
therapy is generally the way i describe
shrooms like if you're ready for it then
it can help you
exactly so how do you well we can start
with that
i've been through a plethora of
therapists
since the age of like 11 when i was
diagnosed with depression and medicated
and each one of them has been an
absolute catastrophe
like you know like a catastrophe and and
it ended up with me well let's let's
start with this how
how do you identify a good life coach or
a good therapist
um i think someone who you respect you
trust
you you also have
other people you respect and trust
who've worked with them
that have got have gotten results um
so that's why the way i really look at
it if they've worked with other people
who are
just as complex or unique or different
as me
and they've been able to find peace or
results or progress
then okay something i'm open to
okay okay i think it's also someone that
holds me accountable
uh like doesn't let me get away with
stuff holds me accountable
but is also compassionate and kind and a
great listener as well
okay um did you ever have difficulty
this is one of the things i've been
having difficulty with um did you ever
have difficulty trusting your intuition
uh yes because
well here's the thing i think i've
always known
to trust it but sometimes i don't listen
and do what my intuition says
or it might be confusing like well is
this in total alignment with my life or
am i supposed to do this business deal
or am i supposed to be with this person
am i supposed to do this thing or am i
able to make it work
and i think you know i would love for
life to be a hundred percent of the time
this is a f yes or an f no
but i think a lot of times it's like
well not everything is my way the way i
want it
all the time the perfect conditions the
perfect environment
life is messy people are messy and what
am i willing to create with someone or
what am i willing to create in this
moment
in order to feel good in this moment so
i i think i've
always been able to trust it but i don't
always listen to it and act on it
okay but like looking back if you
understand like looking back in your
life you're like okay
my intuition was telling me something
there was something off or there was
something that wasn't
feeling right but i kept doing it
anyways and
now looking back i realized i probably
should have like my intuition was right
but for whatever reason i did that thing
okay so let's start with relationships
then
that might be an interesting place to
start how do you
how do you how do you go with your gut
in relationships if if there are like
external things telling you that you're
going in the wrong direction
well in the past i
have gone with the the desires
the emotions that i feel like is my
intuition
but it's more of like my i don't know
what if we want to call desires or
animal instincts or attraction
or chemistry as opposed to is this
really hitting
um compatibility and chemistry
at the same time and so i think i've had
to learn
and i think i'm constantly learning this
process of like okay well
is this the the relationship that's
gonna hit all the areas of my life
perfectly i'm not sure if that's even
possible maybe
maybe it is but i think there's someone
that you're gonna be with or people that
you're going to be with over time that
are
here to teach you something and my my
challenge has been i i have repeated the
pattern many times
to learn lessons that i've never learned
and i keep repeating the patterns until
i learned them so for me it's it's
miserable how that works yeah i keep i
keep attracting
certain moments or events and whether it
be intimate
relationships or business relations
things like that until i learn how to
overcome those triggers
the traumas that whatever i'm holding on
to so relationships are
for me the greatest teacher
okay and has have has therapy helped you
with figuring out
triggers and our problems in your past
relationships
do you think that they were caused by
your trauma or
just a discrepancy between you and the
other person
uh well
i think i have attracted
the person many times in my past
the pattern that i've recognized is i've
attracted the person where i can feel
the most validated where i can feel the
most
needed the most acknowledged where i
could
help the most where i could kind of
support them in their growth or
overcoming some challenge that i feel
like
okay i'm capable of and that's been a
pattern of my past
and i've also been an extreme people
pleaser
where um when i feel a sense of love
and connection and an intimate
relationship in my past
i would do when someone would get upset
or angry with me or didn't like
something or
whatever they had a different point of
view and they wanted me to do their
thing
i would give in over and over again
because they were angry and upset at me
and so i would just give in and say okay
what do you want what do you need let me
do this
fine and i would do it from a place of i
don't want to do this i'm
i'm out of integrity with myself but i'm
doing it to keep the peace
i'm doing it to please you and
i used to say man this person doesn't
understand me this person doesn't get me
they keep attacking me they get angry
with me they're not
happy with who i am they're not grateful
for all that i create i used to say that
a lot
and be upset at them then i realized oh
this isn't about them this is about me
abandoning myself me not standing up for
what i want or what i believe in this
moment not saying that they're
right or bad or wrong or anything i'm
not saying i'm right or wrong but just
we want different things in this moment
but i would always abandon myself
to make someone else happy to create a
sense of peace
in that moment an environment of peace
and what i've learned is you can't buy
peace
you can't pay someone off for them to
then be happy because then they'll keep
doing it
uh and they'll never be happy it doesn't
solve the problem
yeah so i would just be like screw this
this person doesn't get me no matter
what i give to them they're never happy
and it's their fault and they're
ungrateful
and uh and i'm out and that that's been
a pattern in my past and and i think
therapy
when i'm able to to go through great
coaching or great therapy
has allowed me to overcome many
different challenges like that
and that's just one that has stood out
in the past many times
okay i'm gonna probe into this therapy
thing a little bit more because i'm
i have a therapist at the moment that i
actually i actually it hasn't been very
many sessions but we're actually getting
along
which is like the ninth person i've
tried i'm like wow this is
i don't want to jinx it but when you
when you're in therapy
do you do it by just like recounting
experiences or
talking about you know what's gone on in
the last week and then working through
that
or are there certain techniques that are
employed
for me for me it's something i did when
i when i
um joined this this current coach
therapist
i was like okay here are the main i kind
of wrote down
i analyzed here are the main challenges
when this happens here's the reaction
when this happens here's how i feel when
this happens this is what's created
way ahead of me i created like an
analysis i was like
i wanted to give this to them of like
here's me self announce
analyzing myself of where i fall short
my breakdowns where this person
triggers me why this is triggering me
where this comes from
because i've been you know doing this
work for eight years with my show and
just interviewing these people where
i've been saying okay coach me how can i
improve
i've been kind of putting all this out
there of my flaws and insecurities for
years
because i'm seeking more patience more
wisdom
more peace in my life uh more tools
to become a better man better human
being and so i kind of laid out this
whole map
this like two or three page thing in my
journal and i sent them a photo of it i
said and then i sent an
audio message to create context because
i don't want to spend
three sessions creating context
personally oh
yeah i was like like i don't want to sit
here for an hour and a half
and tell you about the last week or sit
here for
three sessions and talk about everything
from my childhood
i wanted to address the core things the
things that i know troubled me from my
challenging
from my childhood shared all my traumas
all the big events that have occurred
and why
this triggers me and then then i was
able to come from a place of that well
here's what happened in the last week or
here's what happened two days ago
and why is it there it's their fault
and then having a bigger perspective uh
she's been able to be like well okay
you know this is maybe don't like this
maybe don't agree with this
but why is it triggering you so much and
it's okay to be triggered it's okay to
react
to certain situations and scenarios that
upset you you don't have to be this
peaceful
uh buddha all day long monk and not show
anger and not show emotion
she's not telling me that but she's also
saying why do you need to hold on to it
why
you know how can you not react from a
place of defensiveness
but respond from a place of choosing a
higher level of conscious communication
and that's the practice i'm on i feel
like you know
people like me and you who have content
out there
personal brands putting our message
putting our voice out online
for millions of people to watch
view criticize praise whatever
i only think that we're gonna get more
and more
challenges in the future sure lots of
great opportunities
you know uh business-wise career-wise
those things are to come to us as well
but i think we're gonna get
more and more challenges every year with
trolls negative comments
attacks accusations whatever it might be
just by the nature of what we're doing
i don't know if you've already seen this
in the last couple years with you
creating your show and your content and
no criticism ever
and if we don't learn how to overcome
that
then we're going to be prisoners
prisoners of it we're going to be
stressed we're going to be anxious
and i don't want to be someone that
resents
doing what i'm doing or resents people
who are commenting online
i want to be someone who's able to be
focused on my vision
serve people create something greater
than myself and also
just know like this comes with the
territory and be okay with it i don't
have to like it
but be okay with it for the most part i
really don't
i really don't give a [ __ ] what people
think i like i've got
that aspect of my life i think is okay
um
i'm there there are certain things that
trigger me like if it's
in the last year and a half when my dad
has been sick
i've had trolls come after me being like
what are you
you're taking advantage of your father's
brand you're
trying to hurt him right and and that
makes me extremely angry when it's like
you're you're that it's just it's so
wrong
and it's i think because i was having a
very difficult time when my dad was
really sick
having that on top of it was more than i
could tolerate
and so my like what i i've just dealt
with those people by there's not very
many of them by blocking them
that's just like i don't need you guys
in my life for people who are like
annoyed about political perspectives or
you know why did you have this person on
this person shouldn't be given a
platform that kind of thing i'm like i
get that all the time
yeah yeah and well how do you feel about
that
you know i try to
my whole intention from day one which
was eight years ago starting
my show was i want to have diverse
individuals i want to have diverse
religions religious backgrounds
point of views beliefs ethnicities
industries i want diversity in general
of idea and thought
and i'm trying to figure out which tools
does someone have that can support me
and which tools do someone have that can
support
the audience or anyone that wants to
listen or watch it doesn't mean
that i need to back or agree with 100 of
the things that that person says 100 of
their actions i don't agree with 100 of
my
past actions so i'm not going to agree
with 100 of someone else's actions
their beliefs their values everything
doesn't
mean that i can't learn from them and
for me
i've made that stance in the beginning
it's been more and more challenging
and i've it's been unfortunate because i
i also don't want to do something
where i know it's just going to get
bombarded with attacks and it's going to
be
more it's going to be more annoying to
just
manage and not justify but just like
okay i don't want to deal with this
so how can i do it in a way that works
for me for the audience for
you know people that aren't watching and
that are going to critique it how can i
make it work
for the benefit of all so i've just had
to learn how to do that but i've had
you know that critiques with your dad
being on the show how could you give
this man a platform
ben shapiro you know other people that
uh
maybe my audience isn't used to hearing
or maybe isn't the main
um at least the loudest people that
watch or listen to my show
aren't aren't in agreement with you know
that type of thing so
that's that's been a challenge i got to
navigate but
i feel like we do it pretty good
i figured out uh i have this section
called opposing views so if i bring
somebody
really really out there on like okay i
can
host your opinion but i have to show the
other side
and then i think i yeah i thank you
i'm actually fairly pleased with that
idea it's been very
yeah it's been very difficult to get
it's been difficult to set up
because uh well because they're
contentious issues if you have
contentious subjects on
but uh that's been working out real well
but
yeah there's there's a few people i want
to have there's a few people i wanted to
have on
who want to come on but i'm like um
is this the right time like the climate
of the culture is this
are people going to think that i'm you
know i just people always
misunderstand or misinterpret no matter
and here's the challenge
no matter how much good i've tried to
put out into the world or how much i try
to keep a neutral stance on
on topics
you know for one one instance is like
the vaccine issue
i've had people come on and say you know
no vaccines i've had doctors come on and
say well here's the science that's
talking about
vaccines in favor and
one i put out one clip where someone was
a doctor was talking about
how vaccines have have saved children's
lives for many years
and the science behind it um
not saying what's wrong if you don't
vaccinate but the science is proving in
certain vaccinations that it's that it's
helped kids
with certain illnesses and man i've got
so many moms who are just like attacking
me
how dare you louis like you're you know
you're evil i can't believe you would
endorse something like this i can't
believe you promote this i've listened
to you and watched you for
years and now i'm unsubscribing because
you're hurting people with this
information
and i always say listen i'm bringing
people on with ideas and perspectives
you got to do your own research you've
got to follow the case studies you've
got to follow the science whatever and
make a decision
but it doesn't mean i'm not going to
seek information seek wisdom
that could be beneficial to someone and
it may not be right for you it doesn't
mean you have to do everything i say or
everything someone says
i usually tell those people don't let
the door hate you on the way out all
right right
exactly but but i'm might be a little
bit more disagreeable
maybe i don't know uh okay so i forgot
to ask
every i start the episode every single
time with asking
uh you to give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
and i skipped over that so could we just
do that now in case anyone listening
doesn't know who you are what you do uh
yeah my name is lewis howes i was a very
insecure
child um that used sports
as an outlet to get my anger out my
aggression out and to find
value in myself i ended up becoming
pretty good at sports
had a dream of being an all-american
athlete was a two-sport all-american
athlete then had a dream of playing
professional football went to play arena
football which is kind of like
america's canadian football it's like
not real
professional but you're still getting
paid and so
i was able to go and chase that dream um
then in my first year i got injured you
know i was done by 23
and wasn't sure what i was gonna do the
rest of my life
i was sleeping on my sister's couch for
about a year and a half this was in 2007
2008
when the the housing crisis happened in
america and
uh really wasn't sure who i was
what my identity was anymore where i got
my value
but i started using linkedin as a tool
to connect with people to build
relationships to learn about job
opportunities
and i found out that i was pretty decent
at using linkedin to
connect with the right people and also i
found out i was pretty good at just
marketing and social media in general
for the next few years built up
an online marketing company where we
sold educational courses i taught people
about how to use these different
platforms to
generate leads and and help them get job
opportunities things like that
end up selling that company to my
business partner
and then a year later launched the
school of greatness and that's been my
mission ever since just to
inspire people with uh great
conversations like what you're doing as
well
thank you how how long did it take for
the school of greatness to pick up steam
uh it's funny i was talking to my friend
gabby bernstein who
just launched her show uh this last week
it's i think it's number eight in the
world on apple
yeah or it's somewhere yeah it's called
dear gabby
and um so she's top 10 in the apple and
she was telling me her numbers
uh in the first week and i don't want to
say them publicly but i was like
man that took me five years to get that
many downloads in an episode
uh on my podcast so you're doing great
um it took off within like the first
year i would say like the end of the
first year i started to see some
traction and some like
taking off momentum but this is back in
2013
when people didn't know how to like
where to find the podcast app on their
phone you had to teach people
how to download the app how to subscribe
how to listen like
you had to it was just very clunky so it
had momentum in the sense that my first
year
um i only had 750 000 downloads
and this this was pre youtube and things
like that so
first year 750 000 my second year i
think we had like uh
you know maybe three million downloads
where people are doing that
in their first month now when they're
launching if you have an audience
so it took me years to get to a place of
real
traction and momentum in terms of a
broader reach
but it had the sense of like oh lewis is
doing this thing and no one else is
doing a podcast i'll go on
because i was the only you know kind of
one of my space during that time
okay and your space is literally you're
just talking to people who you think you
can learn from
or how do you choose guests my my
my intention is to find the leading
expert
in their category of something that i'm
fascinated by that i think will help
people improve the quality of their life
so a lot of neuroscientists
psychologists doctors health related
experts
who can optimize the brain body the
heart because
i'm a big believer that if you want to
be great you need to have a great body
then i'm also thinking of people who
who are the you need to have energy you
need to have clear thought you need to
be able to manage your thoughts and you
need to be able to manage your emotions
if you want to actually put your vision
into action
in a in a healthy way that builds
momentum so that starts with mind body
uh emotions then i'm looking for
spiritual masters because i think a lot
of people
don't even know what their dream what
their goals are you know they don't have
anything to aim at they don't know how
to find what that mission or purpose is
on their season or
of life or life right so i'm looking for
the great
spiritual leaders from all religions
whether it be christianity or
or any other religion and i'm trying to
find the wisdom from leaders
in those spaces that might work for me
or might help other people then i'm
thinking about
what are the stories of the greatest
athletes being from sports
i believe athletes at the top of their
game
have had to overcome incredible
adversity and challenges and have had to
endure so much
physical pain mental fortitude for
decades to get to the top
so i'm fascinated by athletes because
they
do a lot of the things right in terms of
learning how to set goals learning how
to manage their time
structuring their calendar learning how
to recover learning how to visualize the
future what they want to create
delayed gratification because these
things take years
you know olympians will spend 16 years
training
for 10 seconds for two minutes
and the delayed the delayed
gratification
of a goal is unbelievable as opposed to
you know uh the instant gratification of
a lot of people today
so i really appreciate the discipline
of great athletes then i'm looking for
people who are number one in their field
whether it be musicians or
artists or activists poets people who
have reached the top
because it's hard to get there
okay that seems to be somewhat similar
to what i'm doing now
of course like you know something i
don't know right
i should can i have that information
exactly
what is something you feel like you've
learned
in the last two years that you didn't
know before that's
dramatically improved the quality of
your life
jesus well from from
podcasts or not from podcasts yeah from
all your
interviews your experiences uh coaching
therapy
conversation with your dad anything well
well honestly this
what we were talking about earlier um
trying to listen to my intuition instead
of
rationalize everything i do is something
that's
dramatically transforming my life and i
think because i was
because really because i was medicated
at such a young age put on ssris and
those really
like they mess with your head i don't
care what anybody
says they mess with your head that's
what they're supposed to do and
um i stopped being able to trust what i
was feeling
so i would just rationalize everything
uh and and now that i'm healthy and i
managed to get over the depression
when i have feelings and i can't
rationalize them
i'm i have this huge discrepancy and it
causes me a lot of like existential
angst uh and so i've been trying to
figure out how to
follow my intuition more like if i have
that gut instinct it's intense
and if i'm like not it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense and i and i
don't follow it it just ruins my life
so i've been trying to speak to people
to kind of delve into that i've had some
interesting
and i'm going to be speaking with some
interesting psychiatrists and
psychologists
to try and delve into that but i would
say that's one aspect
aspect and i've also been looking into
breathing
so there's really something there i've
been implementing that more and more and
more because it takes some
self-discipline and it's kind of
uncomfortable
um but wim hof was a really good episode
and there's really something there so i
went to paul i took a trip
uh to poland i took 13 guys influencers
last year right before the pandemic
and for five days with him and it was
yeah it was a game changer
um for for all of us it was really
powerful and i'd been
studying some of his stuff for a couple
years i've had him on a few times before
but it was just a great boot camp for us
to do every
every single day practice it do it in a
group setting
yeah and i think it really allows you
when we when we master the art of
breathing i feel like it gives us this
incredible power
that we don't have when we're shallow
breathing and i think greatness
and striving to be greater in your life
that's a part of the body and i think
when we breathe
correctly we learn how to do it in times
of stress or how to do it in times of
depression
to get ourselves out of it or we're in
stress to get us
to calm down we can have incredible
power
and get back to focus on our purpose our
mission or
our aim what we're looking to do because
it's really hard to focus
and take action in a meaningful flow
state way
when our breath is out of whack yeah
i completely underestimated it and i've
been shallow breathing
i'm sure lots of people are shallow
breathing or breathing with their
shoulders from for most of my life
100 like i can remember when i was sick
i felt like i couldn't inhale all the
way
that was one of my symptoms was like it
felt like the bottom of my lungs
couldn't fill up
and wim hof style breathing or breathing
into my belly
and then into my shoulders i can't
believe what kind of difference it makes
it's unbelievable have you had have you
had andrew huberman on yet to talk about
his breathing style as well it's really
powerful for the brain and
i had him on but we didn't talk about
breath
have you had james nestor on yet i did
yeah that was powerful too oh
okay i'm having him on soon i'm excited
yeah he's legit he's legit
okay so that that question same question
for you then
what have what's what's changed in the
last couple of years for you something
major you've learned from podcasts or
interviews
i think i think
my greatest teachers have always been
relationships the relationship
of the driver cutting me off and
flipping me off
in in front of me in another car the
relationship
of the person on the street i walk next
to the relationship of
somewhere i'm buying something at a
store my intimate relationship my family
relationships my team dynamics
those relationships are my greatest
teachers and
recognizing why certain things
affect me beyond the place of a
momentarily i don't like this
and moving on why i hold on to things
this coaching and therapy that i've had
in the last few months specifically
has given me more awareness and
consciousness around it whereas before i
used to just be like now this is
everyone else's fault you know it's
it's their problem it's their issue
they're not understanding me or whatever
and now i'm able to kind of take myself
out of my body and see things from a
different point of view
and allow myself to breathe when i'm
triggered
was before i used to be in defensive
guarded reaction mode
i was sexually abused when i was a kid
when i was five by a man that i didn't
know who was an older teenager
and uh it it created a lot of
defensiveness and guardedness in me for
25 years
after that until i started to heal the
process
of of that shame that resentment that
anger
around 30 years old i started doing some
emotional intelligence workshops and
other therapies i that was really the
first time at 30
when i started to look within and
peel back the onions before it was
how do i just dominate when
succeed earn more accomplish more
to make myself feel good or or seen or
heard or better
how can i be better as opposed to how
can i look within
and and heal and so the eight year
journey of that has been
an incredible roller coaster of emotions
some years better than others
uh but in this last few months really
diving into okay why do i still get
triggered
so easily why do i get so defensive so
easily when
when nothing is actually happening
and it's coming back from a place of
like just you know healing
and learning how to um
what a lot of therapists are talking
about like repairing yourself
i think i haven't talked about this with
your dad it's like learning how to
re-parent
that wound that child that didn't know
that didn't get parented or
talked to then um so me having a
kind of a conversation with my younger
self or with the trauma self and being
like okay it's okay
like you can take care of this now here
are the tools you can use to improve
something in this moment
and um and that's what's been powerful
for me and it's a
daily process
i just i just came back from
a dinner party and the conversation i
had with
a comedian there was literally about
healing by kind of pretending you were
taking care
care of your younger traumatized self
that was a conversation i had like an
hour ago wow so that's that's that's
weird
yeah i mean it's weird well it's almost
like it's almost like if we don't learn
how to
whatever you want to call it heal that
childhood
wound reparent yourself whatever you
want to call it
if we don't learn how to uh connect to
it in a way where we can
recover and heal and not saying that
that was okay or it wasn't okay but just
heal from that traumatic experience
big trauma or little traumas and come
from a place of okay what's the tool
moving forward
how can i continue to integrate this
knowing this level of consciousness into
my body
because the trigger comes from like the
i feel very reactive in my body i'm like
i want to fight someone
when someone cuts me off or someone says
something to me negative like
my come from reaction is let's fight
let me get out of this car and come over
to your car and let's it's like
irrational and so i continue to practice
through breathing through meditation
through
intentional uh visualizing of like okay
what is my mission what am i here to do
today this month this year here's my
purpose right now in my life let's stay
focused on that
and not give attention to all the
distractions that will come
not be hurt from something that happened
30 years ago
and still let it affect me today i'm a
prisoner
to that pain still as opposed to healing
it
and using it for good and again it's a
daily process and
a work in progress but that awareness
and then having accountability with
those tools i think once we
learn something and then we say okay i
got it i just feel like that's the time
i'm gonna break down and do something
stupid or hurt myself or hurt someone
else when i'd be like
all right i've learned it all i i've
learned these tools i understand it
i've healed i'm good to go i don't need
support or coaching for the rest of my
life
i feel like i'm always going to want
accountability
to hold me high
exactly the same type of anger response
what is
when things what is it oh like fight
let's go
no it get yeah and and it's completely
completely unreasonable for me
because if i'm out somewhere or if i'm
or if it's like a relationship
argument i'm like like a
thin small female so i'm not going to be
able to like take on
a male counterpart so it's completely d
like it's dangerous
right it's not dangerous in my
relationship but i mean i had the same
kind of reaction when i was a teenager
and it got to the point where i was like
i'm gonna have to take self-defense
classes because i'm so volatile that i'm
gonna get angry i'm gonna provoke
somebody and i'm gonna have to protect
myself
like it it was ridiculous um do you
think there's something around
the age of 30 that hits that allows you
to kind of look back
and think maybe i have some issues i
mean for me it was 30
because i had multiple breakdowns in my
life and so i don't know if people
just have this at 30 but i had my
business was
like partnership was falling apart um
i had a girlfriend at the time that was
breaking down like every week something
was happening where i was like i'm a
constant breakdown
and i just felt like i didn't
know how to manage the emotions inside
of me
i didn't know how to manage the way i
was feeling
and so i would go play sports i play
pickup basketball a lot and i this is
what i was trained to do okay you take
your anger out on the football field on
the basketball court and you
channel it into athletics that's what i
always learned
um and so i would do that
at 30 29 30 i was doing that i was like
okay i'm angry
let me go play basketball because i
don't want to hit someone i'm not going
to scream my girlfriend i'm not you know
i'm not going to do those things so what
do i how do i manage this or otherwise i
explode inside
go play basketball and then i would take
the aggression out on other players
on the basketball court and this is
where i started getting trouble where i
got a fight on a basketball court
literal fist fight in the middle of a
pickup basketball game
that had nothing on the line it was
supposed to be a fun game
but i got triggered the other guy got
triggered and we started fighting each
other
and afterwards i remember saying to
myself what am i doing i'm a 30 year old
grown ass man getting in a fight in
beverly hills
on a pickup basketball game this is
supposed to be fun there's nothing
at stake here there's no one watching
and i'm getting
triggered and reactive to the fact where
i get in a physical fist fight
this is that was a wake-up call for me
luckily
like no one got hurt everything was fine
but
who knows something stupid could happen
i could have got stabbed or someone
could have gotten really hurt or
whatever like i have no idea
i was like wow i have a lot to lose and
my emotions
are in control of me i'm not in control
of my emotions
i'm allowing my emotions i'm allowed to
feel the emotions
and take them out on other people and
that was a wake-up call
where i was like i need some support i
need some coaching some therapy some
workshops some freaking
whatever i'll try whatever get the sweat
lodges do anything i'll try
something to see what works and
that was really part of the process of
me
learning about vulnerability i wasn't a
vulnerable human being before 30.
i wasn't willing to let people see who i
was
my pain what i'd been through because
i'd been conditioned as a man
growing up that you don't show pain you
don't show emotion
in that way anger is okay but you can't
be vulnerable you can't cry
that's what i was conditioned and
when i started to go through some of
these
workshops and therapies and coaches and
stuff like that i
i opened up for the first time about
being sexually abused and i
it felt like i was gonna die when i said
this for the first time it felt like i
was literally if anyone ever knew that i
had been sexually abused in the way that
i've been abused
no one would ever love me people would
shame me for the rest of my life
i'd have no friends i'd make no money
and i'd be alone
that was the irrational fear that
consumed my life
um about this about the shame that i was
holding on to i'm not saying it was okay
to have that but that's just how i was
feeling so i didn't have the tools
i didn't have the awareness the tools
the the the model of someone
who looked like me who grew up like me
who
went out there online or publicly and
was like i've been sexually abused
and here's how to deal with it like i
just never saw that
and so i literally thought i was the
only one and
i was like i must be wrong i must be a
bad person i must be useless
worthless unlovable for this to happen
and i need to hide this i need to mask
myself
to look good to be good to accomplish
to hide the pain hide the shame
and it worked in the sense of like i
accomplished i did at least i
accomplished my goals i was able to do
things
but man was i alone sad
insecure inside for many many years
and i didn't learn true vulnerability
until 30 when i started to practice it
and it's extremely uncomfortable it was
for me
and but i also found out wow
this is probably the greatest superpower
in the world
actually revealing who you are to
someone in a vulnerable way
doesn't make you weak
in the right context in the right
setting of the right people
it really makes you powerful
and connects you to people in a stronger
way
and again i think you need to know when
and where and who
to be able to be open to and things like
that and the more i practiced it over
the last eight years
the more that is true and unfortunately
some people are using that in a way with
social media
to just be vulnerable or play victim
consistently where they gain attention
and connection
and i think okay you can you can totally
see the difference
right right right you can feel it you
can like okay they're just posting every
day about this
as opposed to like hey guys i'm really
scared to share something i've been
thinking about it for a while i want to
share it
and uh here's what i'm going through
type of thing so
but it's it's definitely a superpower
and it's
i believe it's actually what's allowed
me to continue to grow my show
so much because when i bring a big guest
on right away i'm just like you know
here's what i'm going through like the
first thing you talked about when we got
here
i i don't know how to be surface i don't
know how to be surface
i'm just like oh yeah i'm i'm struggling
with this right now i'm going through
this and
uh you know here's where i feel like i
failed yesterday
i'm just go right into it and i
i think it connects people stronger than
than surface level conversations so
yeah wow wow okay
that spoke to me quite a bit what spoke
to you about it
okay well okay so you said you were
conditioned to not cry because you're
you're a man and then that and that
happens to men right just society i mean
maybe it happens to women too but i
think from from growing up
well the peers and the class and the the
i think it's a bit it's a bit different
yeah it's a bit different like you get
teased if you cry but not the same way
you do if you're male for sure
um when i was in grade two i i remember
i was upset about something i'd been
diagnosed with arthritis and i was like
i'm not gonna cry anymore because that's
weak and i can remember in the
schoolyard because i was i was upset
about something and i was starting to
cry and i was like i'm not gonna cry
anymore because that's weak
and i think that just [ __ ] me up until
this year really
right well yeah because i've noticed
like
if you're in an argument um so women
tend to cry
easier than men right so if you're in an
argument and you have that
and i get that urge to cry and i just
stuff it down i think i just hide it
somewhere
in me and it's just stored yeah so
i've yeah and so in the last couple of
years i've gotten better at if i'm
really upset about
something you know i'll go have a cry
and then i'll feel better
and then i don't have to carry around
this horrible negative energy that just
poisons everybody around me
for the rest of the day until i store it
somewhere and
then it just erupts later like i i don't
know if that makes sense or not but
i don't think yeah i don't think hiding
those
i don't think hiding your pain somewhere
and makes it go away
i think you just store it somewhere yeah
i think there's i think there's one
thing
there's one there's one thing about
dumping
your feelings on someone else or or
saying
i feel angry so i'm not gonna store it
so let me scream at you
for what i'm angry about yes there's one
thing that
you know i don't think that's healthy i
think if you're feeling something the
momentum no not if you can express it
you can
but i think it's always okay how can i
do this in a place that's helpful for me
for the other person for the situation
that's why i think journaling i mean i'm
screaming a pillow a lot i this is
something i do i'm like
yeah yeah [ __ ] you know it's
like oh i feel better
but doing that in front of another
person i don't think it's healthy
and they're gonna be like you're a
little crazy right now so
um i think it's finding activities and
ways to
move the emotions out of our body this
is why for me working out is really
helpful i'm boxing twice a week and it's
like okay i can
get it out i can punch it out i'm
running i'm doing stuff that makes me
tired
where i can process it through my mind
my heart and then just release it
through sweat
i think journaling i think screaming i
think generally and screaming through a
pillow
is really healthy you know for me these
things
having therapy to talk about these
things so you don't hold on to them is
really
helpful and also talking to the person
that you're frustrated with
in a healthy way i think is the way we
as humans
should strive to be i don't know if i'm
able to be that way
fully um but
not stuffing it and saying okay this
really made me angry i'm gonna stuff it
and not share it
but learning how to share something from
a place of listen what you said really
frustrated me and i'm not going to
scream i'm not going to yell
but i'm going to let you know so i don't
hold on to it and i'm going to take some
space and time
and i'm going to get this out you know i
think that's the way we should be so yes
that's that's what i've been working on
i i definitely tend to stuff it in
rather than like explode and i don't
give it away like i've been in arguments
with other people where they're giving
me their emotion and i'm like i don't
want that
i don't do that i do the stuffing but
it's not healthy um
the wim hof breathing has been helpful
going to have a cry like i'll be like i
just i need a minute go cry in the
bathroom come out
like okay i'm feeling better um uh my
therapist the other week she said
identify exactly how you're feeling this
is just it's stuff that you should teach
kids absolutely like identify
how you're feeling put it into words
like
i am what you said made me feel
frustrated she gave me this like chart
of feeling words i was like
i am feeling this this is what i'm
feeling something you said
triggered this and now i'm feeling like
this
it's like ugh it's like i'm starting at
like four-year-old level
did your dad teach you this when you
were growing up
no like we were we i grew up
our family was very rational so when we
had arguments
a lot of it was you know trying to talk
through it like that was a lot of it
talking through it so they weren't
put away but my childhood was seriously
complicated because
i i was so sick and i was so
angry that a lot of the emotions i had
weren't reasonable
so the only way i managed to deal with
them is i journaled i journaled
all the time um but a lot of it was okay
that's an unreasonable way of thinking
i'll just put it away because it doesn't
make any sense
and so i think because of how sick i was
it's just i
i wasn't able to learn all these coping
mechanisms but i don't know
i don't know if i've met very many
people who've learned them as a kid like
i think
parents who had this perfect childhood
with their parents taught them all the
right ways
and they got this from school and
everything it's like i don't know either
that's why
literally when i was going through these
multiple breakdowns in my life with
relationships and fights and
business it was all happening at the
same time
right when i was hitting 30. i was like
man i thought i knew a lot like because
i've accomplished a lot
in terms of business and money and
sports accomplishments and
i was like i thought i knew a lot i
thought i knew the answers
i thought i was smart but actually i'm
in pain a lot inside
and i haven't figured out the art of
fulfillment i figured out
the science of success and
accomplishment but not
the art or magic of fulfillment
of like how to feel fulfilled and how to
feel
peace and feel
loved i didn't know how to do that
i was playing the game society's way of
doing things
and that's why for me
i was like i need to go to something
of what they wish they would have taught
me in school i wish school taught me how
to deal with failure how to deal with
heartbreak how to deal with these
emotions i wish
because this is life it's not calculus
and i don't know yes it is but it's the
most important things i feel like are
understanding your thoughts and emotions
and how to alchemize your thought into a
reality
into a dream into something tangible for
me that's what's the most meaningful
part of life how to feel loved and give
love
that's the meaning that's the magic and
the fulfillment of it
and so i was like i wish school would
have created this for me
but it didn't i need to create a new
school i need to attend this school
is there one out there i was like i'm
going to create it the school of
greatness
not the school of success because i've
already accomplished a lot of success i
need to figure out another level
of fulfillment greatness okay i'm going
to go create it
i didn't know where this one is out
there i was like i'm going to go ask
these people the smartest people from
all walks of life and figure out
what do they do how can i learn from
them and that's i'm still
on that journey you know eight years
later i'm still like okay i've learned a
lot but
man i got a long way to go
that's awesome do you think
do you have any suggestions for okay so
the reason i started seriously looking
into therapy and ways to like
regulate my emotions better or
understand what was going on was because
i have a three and a half year old
and i was and she was mimicking things i
was doing
what were you doing that you were that
she was mimicking the most that you
realized i don't want her to do that
you know if i was upset and i wasn't
saying any this was the part so
i'd stuff down those emotions and just
be like i'll just wait till it goes away
like i'll just be calm breathe
ish not really breathe just like wait
till it goes away
um she would just channel what i was
feeling
so and i at first i i was like that
cannot possibly be related right
but but then i was thinking you know
when i grew up my my
i i'd pick up sometimes when my mom had
this kind of cold she could
ice down a room really well um and i was
like
and it used to upset me as a kid and i
was like oh my god
is that what i'm doing now am i like am
i stuffing that emotion down
icing out this room and is is my toddler
freaking out because of that
and it and it happened enough times that
i was like oh my like i really have to
figure out what's going on and there's
got to be a better way to deal with this
because
i think i'm just doing what i saw happen
and now it's affecting my three and a
half year old
child who just wants to be loved and
express love and
be happy i know and she's freaking out
because i'm freaking out i was like
that's
terrible yeah anyway well that's that's
good that's good that you recognize you
saw it and you're like let me take
action
not let me keep stuffing it and make
them wrong for how they're showing up
to my and reacting to me but like okay
how can i improve myself
i think that takes a lot of yeah that
takes a lot of courage
for all humans but i think for parents
specifically to say
okay i i felt like i know a lot i feel
like i'm a good person which you are
and you do but how can i continue to
prove for my children
oh yeah definitely i mean people have
enough issues they don't have to pass
on issues like if you had zero issues
growing up you're still going to have
issues in an adult you don't need like
generational issues passed on to you
what do you think what do you think if
you could only
provide your daughter with three tools
for life and and then
you disappear hypothetical scenario and
you won't be able to teach them anything
else but you could provide them whether
you taught them or they
learned the the map to master these
three skills or
tools what would those be
three tools okay one i'm taking from my
dad because this really helped
me and he told me never use your illness
when i
was diagnosed in grade two never use
your illness as an excuse
right and so that would be one lesson
it's
it doesn't really matter what happens to
you because
really terrible things can happen that
are really unfair
but you can't use it as an excuse
because if you use it as an excuse it'll
just destroy your life
right so that would be that would be one
i would put
more of an emphasis on um
being emotional is okay so so at the
moment
we're just learning this together i'm
like you're feeling
like what you're feeling right now is
anger that's called anger angry what
you're feeling right now is anger and
like
you know you can't hit people but you
can count and you can
breathe and it's okay that you're
feeling angry like so i would
i would probably well and i'm teaching
her that
feeling emotional is okay if you need to
have a cry
have a cry crying can make you feel
better like all these things
so that and what would
oh okay and then the third one would be
it it almost doesn't matter what bad
thing happens in your life
you can get over basically anything
like you'll get confronted with disease
and death and these these horrible
things
um you might not have any money like
lots of things will happen
but you have the power and the strength
to figure out how to get out of that and
then to get to a better place
um so you sound like a great mom
i'm trying it's really hard it's really
what's the hardest part about being a
mom this is
my podcast i know i'm just curious i'm
curious
what's what's the hardest part um
i have a lot of guilt like i'm pretty
career oriented and i really like work i
really like succeeding
i'm in incredibly attracted to status
like like i know these things about me i
want to be the best
that's great that you acknowledge it
yeah yeah and i i
like it i don't think there's anything
wrong with that but then i have guilt
about you know maybe i should have been
i have a nanny
i was home for the first year but i got
a nanny and i was like maybe i'm a bad
person for
for wanting to work and having a kid
i've gotten over that but it took like
two years
um i love that you have the courage to
guilt
oh the guilt yeah sorry to cut you off
but i love that you have the courage to
say
i love status
i love having status i love status i
think that's i think most people
are aren't willing to say that
you know they're like oh yeah i'm part
of it is because i want to do these
things but also i like status and this
gives me status
oh yeah no definitely i mean there there
are other things like i'd really like to
improve myself and i'd like to
decrease suffering and i want to help
people and and that's
that's really up there that's why i do a
whole bunch of talk about autoimmune
disorders because i don't really like
talking about it but that's to help
people
but i mean i like seeing how far i can
go
because it's it's crazy if you put your
mind towards something how far
you can go and it doesn't just go for me
it's like everybody has that capacity
and for some reason they're told
especially nowadays that
it's out of their reach for some reason
like a lot of this oppression stuff is
that
oh you're female or you're sick like or
all these things and there it's all it's
basically just a lie
i know yeah
i hear you yeah
okay what was that question you just
asked me um
what was that the three skills or tools
that you would you yeah
you do that you do that question too
what are the three skills
i don't have a child i don't have kids
but you would
instead i would still a child if i could
only give three
tools that's a hard question i think the
first one
is how to believe in yourself
no matter what is happening around you
no matter how many people say you can't
how many people doubt you and how many
people say you won't
accomplish or be able to do that thing
learning how to believe in yourself no
matter what is happening around you
i'm a big believer that self-doubt is
the killer of dreams
i think that we can have all the talent
all the credentials
all the degrees all the the world saying
lead us you have the skills you have the
talent
but if we don't learn how to overcome
the inner
critic that says you can't do it if we
don't learn how to overcome that
it doesn't matter what we how much
school we get how much how physically
talented we are it doesn't matter
so the ability to believe in yourself no
matter what the condition or experience
is around you that'd be the first one
believing in self
under extreme adversity number two would
be
learning how to master
your your thoughts and emotions uh i
think the
thoughts that we have
consume us they've consumed me most of
my life until i
learned how to be uh the leader of them
as opposed to a reactor to them
um and my emotions took over my body i
remember
feeling especially with like heartbreak
and past relationships when i was like i
don't know
in my early 20s i would lay in the fetal
position for days
sometimes because i felt like this
person doesn't love me anymore i'm
unlovable or whatever i didn't know how
to manage the emotions
and so learning to navigate and be
a leader of your thoughts and emotions
as opposed to
uh them controlling and consuming you
from the inability to take action that'd
be the second one and the third one
would be the thing that has popped in my
head would be the
the ability to serve others at the
highest level
i believe the greatest gift we can
receive is when we
serve other people and we feel better
we we make an impact we contribute
when we're in service whether that's
with a family member friend a community
the world doesn't matter
but learning how to serve and help
others
and not make your life all about me me
me what do i need what do i'm not
getting
who's not doing something for me uh but
how can i show up for for others in a
powerful way so those three things
awesome okay louis if people
don't know who you are and they need to
find you how can they find you
lewishowes.com or school of greatness or
lewis house anywhere online on social
media
okay thank you very much for coming on
that was great appreciate it
[Music]
you